[Music]
new tonight at 11 reforming nevada's
juvenile justice system
that's the goal of a new bill that was
recently introduced to state lawmakers
in carson city
erko mana joining us now live to explain
why some say it could really make a
difference
orca well denise the idea is to address
the school to prison pipeline which
we've illustrated here
that's where young offenders are
funneled
into the criminal justice system even
though rehabilitation would be a better
option
assembly bill 230 here would essentially
act as a barrier
so other options can be explored
youth should be treated as youth nevada
assemblyman c.h miller introducing a
juvenile justice bill with that goal in
mind
ab-230 would change the process of
direct filing which places young people
who've committed certain crimes
directly into the adult criminal system
what we need to do
is at least put the stop gap in place
where they have to see a juvenile judge
first which is what this bill would do
those judges would check if
rehabilitation through the juvenile
system
is possible for those teens instead of
sending them to prison
assemblyman miller says it's a simple
step that can make a world of difference
when juveniles go to the adult criminal
system
they most likely will return to the
criminal system
and that's what we want to stop but the
bill with an amendment provided by the
clark county district attorney's office
would not apply to those who commit
crimes such as murder and attempted
murder the hope is to eventually include
them and that's why the aclu of nevada
is sponsoring a different amendment
which would require a deeper look at
what resources are needed to make that
happen
really working to build a robust
juvenile justice system
that can hold all kids regardless of any
crime they may have committed
but the first step is ab230 just passing
this bill doesn't get it done we still
have a lot more to do
again the bill was just introduced and
next it'll need to be discussed in a
committee work session
before it's voted on reporting live
tonight orca mana 8 news now